baby
on November 5th 1990 congressional
legislation was signed into law
freezing 50% of US aid to the military
of El Salvador release of the aid is
based in part on the US State
Department's evaluation of the human
rights performance of both sides in the
11-year old Civil War many of the
incidents in the following report from
El Salvador occurred during the period
November 29th through December 13 1990
when this newly passed US legislation
required the State Department to closely
monitor and evaluate the actions of both
the FMLN and the Salvadoran government
and its military the Salvadoran
military's Information Agency Corp refa
refused our requests for an interview
the government's human rights agency
canceled a scheduled interview the US
Embassy would not allow a videotaped
interview many of the Salvadorans we
spoke to would not allow their full
names and identities to be used for fear
of reprisals by Salvadoran military and
security forces the people of El
Salvador are caught in a web of terror
trapped between the military forces of
the arena
forces of the FMLN no one is safe in the
Civil War
over the last 11 years the United States
has sent more than four billion dollars
in aid to El Salvador's military forces
and government over these same 11 years
more than 75,000 civilians have been
killed or disappeared thousands more
have been tortured
today the Salvadoran people continue to
suffer as a persistent pattern of brutal
human rights violations grips the nation
who's behind the killings the
disappearances the torture has u.s. aid
contributed to peace and democracy in El
Salvador or merely strengthened a
military regime that wages low-intensity
warfare on its own citizens the answers
to these questions may determine the
future status of US aid to El Salvador
it's abusing the Salvadoran people the
government in military or the FMLN
Amnesty International says the great
majority of the human rights violations
are committed by the arena government
and its military forces but the torture
that the government does in some of the
bodies that we've seen have had the
faces chopped away the faces burned the
eyeballs gouged out the cigarette
burnings electrical shocks cigarettes on
the genitals and the breasts of women
repeated rapes humiliation but
Salvadoran President crystianna's chief
of staff blames the FMLN yet M'Lynn is a
hardcore violent very violent Marxist
Leninist organization that is an
amalgamation of five different guerrilla
groups but civilians living in the
countryside say government forces
attacked the village of san simone is in
the state of lucid of 10 it lies among
the Lemp a river for Salvadoran armed
forces massacred 200 civilians mostly
women and children in 1981 residents of
san simone say government forces in u.s.
supplied planes and helicopters bomb and
strafe them an average of two to four
times a year when we visited San Simone
on December 9th 1990 the village had
been attacked that morning
pero no Fatah keep on here we are very
sad the community is full of children
and adults and the helicopter was
attacking us so we're a cooperative man
here we are completamente between the
rock and the hard place Saturnian de
película the walls of the san simone
school are parked with bullet holes from
a previous attack by government military
forces villagers say a teacher and two
children were inside at the time north
of san simone teenage girls are
reportedly being raped by members of the
Salvadoran military a social worker says
the women are threatened with death if
they report these crimes
director momento you have to now we
don't know one case cousin is where see
the rape has been caused by the FMLN all
the cases to mention before have been
caused by the army the government army
the army sings and consent to the
villages still pretending to attack
guerrillas diesel and heavy shootout
they are all lies interim government
they come into the homes take the young
girls out Laura Casey anytime children
and they rape them he can they threaten
them and they make sure they know that
if they say a word they will be killed
and their families may be killed
out of fear those girls say nothing the
rural hamlet of La Mora in the state of
coos Kaitlyn was bombed by the
Salvadoran military on November 29th
1997 US supplied planes rocketed and
machine gun the town
NEADS exploded on rooftops has
terrorized residents huddled outside the
ceiling in this bedroom was ripped open
as children lay on the bed below
residents of LaMotta blame the military
these and similar attacks the Minister
of the Interior says it's the FMLN that
attacked civilians especially during
their second offensive gun design with
the many children like them many old
people the many women in excluding
pregnant women a set died in this
offensive these are not military target
he's dealing another give it a la cocina
he's a developer Delaware another
resident of Lamora point out the damages
to his home he says nearly 100 soldiers
alarmed his property and terrorized his
family for seven hours the woman who
lives here says it more than 30 soldiers
stormed her house as bombs were falling
nearby she said they fired into the home
where she and her family were hiding and
then accused them of collaborating with
the guerrillas another Calladine we said
we don't collaborate with it either side
not true you want to be here they said
that you don't collaborate with that
they collaborate with a guerilla
actually that's not true
we're talking about it but with nobody
okay so nobody can accuse me of
collaborating with the other side from
the customer as a renegade that's what
we said to them
then they took my husband Kalia why
don't tell that I took him to
interrogate him want to joined a group
of Salvadorans and Americans requesting
that the US Embassy protect LaMotta from
further attacks by the military the
group asked an embassy human rights
officer to visit the village and
document the damage
in the capital city of san salvador the
human rights of students labor leaders
teachers priests and nuns are also being
violated the arena party says it's
because they're members of the FMLN then
you have union people students are very
much members of the FMLN and then you
have intellectuals leftist intellectuals
who also members of the FMLN so it's an
amalgamation of different groups but
Amnesty International disagrees what
they try to do is first as they as a
military talks about is they try to cut
off the head of the opposition
sometimes those may be the union leaders
and maybe the students and maybe the
teachers it may be the priests the nuns
the religious workers that they go after
to try to take away the moral authority
or those people who talk about justice
and then they go after everybody else on
top of what you have there in that
country is you have some random killing
some torture being done by the
guerrillas which unleashes even more
torture and death by the extreme right
and by the best squads and by the
government a woman who works for the
10,000 residents of san salvador left
homeless by a major earthquake in 1986
describes how she was tortured by the
Salvadoran military so they start
watching you here and they are on your
head everywhere it lime folder tied up
yes yeah we have to stand it for 72
hours without sleeping without eating
without drinking a drop of water they I
was standing up without moving Dingwell
because it me out of exhaustion you fell
make il play start kicking you all over
again
last day they put the plastic hood on my
head
they threw in this hood everyone
cigarette smoke and snot they put it on
my head tight two men sat on me my hands
tied I felt I was being strangled
remember I couldn't read any longer they
put that hood on five times yet the
fifth time I said it means stop
torturing me I can I cannot say what you
want me to say I am because I am not who
you say I am and if you feel I'm a
burden to the society kill me kill me I
yell it yet I couldn't almost talk any
longer at that point that's when the
tortures stop that's the torture they do
they are in the military quarters and
they have to end up only here in
national terms a National Guard and all
the military poets men and the torture
you inflict on people Ganapati
only because I voicing what they need
what we need then working to survive
them ecology that they torture well and
that what our armed forces in our
government are all about Mima you all
pay always that padula getting another
persecuted group is Kanaga days active
women who try to find those killed you
disappeared people have to understand in
the country life El Salvador we can be
considered dangerous to the government
if you are just raising questions about
the disappearance of your family member
they seek to punish these
provide support and medical services to
the families and orphans of the
disappeared two women were killed when
coma that his headquarters was bombed in
1989 the group's director says she was
raped repeatedly by a military officer
while imprisoned
it's awful it's repulsive he said I'm
going to rape you but you better not
tell anybody about it tomorrow I said if
you don't do it I won't tell you don't
have to do it because I began to fight
him because I was angry but he took off
my clothes he listened yet and he was
saying Nick do you like it
he caressed me and pinched me and how do
I explain it's something difficult to
understand I try not to be affected by
it I mean when he was done he hugged me
and said maybe I won't let you leave
because I liked it the offices of
finatus the national federation of
salvador and trade unions was bombed by
the Salvadoran military in October 1989
ten people were literally blown to
pieces and many more were injured one
was a West Oh Andrew
Federation was in prison for a year and
a half and tortured he is here it's true
that several point isn't it by the FMLN
will you see the coincide with our point
in which we agree with some of their
ideas a plenty but that doesn't mean
that were part of the FMLN this is
Venice recorded by the government
ammonia 7 to make us look like a friend
I am FLN well ii know so much but that's
not true
Bettis an idiot who didn't we have our
own legal recognition idiot are we are
recognized by the Ministry of Labor
anonymous and we don't carry arms Allah
our arms of the Labor Code soon and the
several petitions for indications but
the government in order to justify its
repression but it would be to justify
its terrorist actions against us say we
are the FMLN
which will the committee many Americans
we don't know what's done with their tax
money with their taxes are used to bomb
houses look children old people and
women even those have and they don't
know it the Salvadoran government's
Minister of the Interior acknowledges
the military has committed atrocities
against the civilian population but he
says it's the work of a few rogue
officers on a veto because there have
been occurrences in both them which are
huddled horrible distasteful in which
certain elements of the Salvadoran
military have been involved going down
and this is a very unfortunate well be
also because there is not a distinction
made between the entire military
institution where and some of the
occurrences of certain Engel element in
the Army in the Minotaur's and it's not
the institutionalized practice although
some people might see it that way this
is less isolated incidents of certain
people just as in organizations all
around the world
I in Finnish might occur involving
people who are a member of certain
organization shal size do not involve
the organization in kir organize assume
the moon again Amnesty International
disagrees saying the military's problem
is widespread and systemic well it is
very systemic and it's systemic in the
fact that the government is has allowed
it to go on they've used it to their
advantage and they've participated in it
it is part of the system in El Salvador
it has not changed in the last 10 years
on the side of the assassinations of the
six priests killed by Salvadoran
military forces in November 1989
we spoke with a colleague of the slain
Jesuits we asked father know Julio
parados who fears for his life on a
daily basis why the priests were killed
borge Aida akina's Napoleon Gaga because
they were who couldn't be silent with
the reasons because they were there and
couldn't be accused of anything they had
no legal reason to take them to the
court they had no [ __ ] recently Jame
them only or deport them so they killed
a lot more philippa assess University
says for being at the service of the
Salvadorean people or for trying to make
them just a little bit less the US
Congress could a portion of its aid to
El Salvador in part because the
Salvadoran government wasn't conducting
a thorough investigation of the massacre
of the priests but the Iranian
government says the investigation has
been professional and complete we are
now in the midst of
implement an individual reform process
in this country it is not something that
you can do overnight but nevertheless
will feel extremely extremely pleased
with the way that the judicial system in
general and just some more in particular
has handled this case the Interior
Minister agrees saying international
experts approved of the way the
investigation was conducted
but Amnesty International doesn't see it
that way we have yet to see a full
investigation but the government has
tried to do in publicly notable cases to
single out some soldiers and say they
were the ones responsible racially lower
echelon individuals but really in fact
the decisions everyone knows came at a
higher level we would ask that that the
government allow individual
investigators to go in and to provide
the information and to see that the
perpetrators were prosecuted I don't
think this will happen under the
president government as US foreign aid
furthered the cause of peace in El
Salvador
its government says yes but most
Salvadorans we spoke to say no a
political opposition leader comments on
American aid and the cause of peace in
some way we have been waging one of the
most important reason why we have been
waiting a war for more than 10 years
because of American hate so in that
sense I would say that American read
with the American taxpayer has not
helped for peace because the opposite
tuned for more destruction more
privation suffering a war dr. Unger also
says it takes more than an election to
make a democracy chosen arena valid we
have three elections you will continue
critique elections I mean there is not
just important to win but the winner has
power and not the power remains of the
hands of the army so the votes are the
real source of power and not accounts
despite the documentation of ongoing
human rights violations against
Salvadoran civilians perpetrated mostly
by the salvage
military and despite the fact that the
arena government either cannot or will
not stop this abuse and despite the fact
that the State Department has been
mandated to monitor and report human
rights abuses by both the Salvadoran
military and the FMLN
President Bush authorized the release a
forty two point five million dollars in
military aid to El Salvador on January
15th 1991 reporting from El Salvador
susan de Brava for behind the headlines
I didn t manatorian
aid to the people and a country like El
Salvador is a problem
inadequate monitoring of a distribution
civil war and government corruption make
it difficult to get the aid words needed
an assistant to US congressman George
Brown says most US non-lethal aid ends
up in Salvadoran military coffers that
leaves that the other 320 million as
economic and developmental assistance
and studies have shown that
approximately three-quarters of that 320
million really go toward military
purposes in the war effort so it leaves
really only about eighty million dollars
out of 400 million dollars that goes to
towards anything that can be called
developmental assistance and
unfortunately the people I saw down here
this past week told me they've never
seen any US aid or even any Salvadoran
government aids if the US government
can't or won't get aid to those who
desperately need it can the large
international relief organizations
deliver an American doctor who's been
delivering medical aid to El Salvador
for ten years says no because the high
profile relief organizations try to
remain apolitical there are
organizations that try to do that like
the International Committee of the Red
Cross like DRI
UNICEF but unless one is willing to get
in El Salvador and confront the
government with their practices it's
very hard to to carry out those missions
and most most agencies aren't willing to
to involve themselves to that extent
because confronting the government even
in a respectful way based on
international law it is to invite being
labeled a subversive
the director of Santa Barbara based
direct relief International says Abe can
find its mark if the distribution is
monitored you have a lot of leverage
because you can restrict your donations
by virtue of saying if we don't have
control if we don't have documentation
if you won't allow us to spot-check then
basically we'll go somewhere else the
DRI admits it has no staff in El
Salvador and relies on written reports
photographs and pre-announced visits to
verify the aid deliveries and sometimes
this system breaks down take for
instance the case of humanitarian aid
raised at Santa Barbara's beachside
festival clothing manufacturers George
Ann and Milan Melvin raised thousands of
dollars every year for the people in El
Salvador they convinced their garment
industry pals to donate merchandise and
all the proceeds go to help those
ravaged by the Salvadoran Civil War in
1989 it gave twenty thousand dollars to
DRI an earmark debt for specific
Salvadoran clinics DRI gave it to the
Salvadoran American Foundation or from
some to disperse the shipment went down
and it turned out that it was not
distributed to our clinics and we were
very upset carlos attributes the snafu
to miscommunication and says she hasn't
had a problem with foo sam since then
myelin Melvin says he was disappointed
but not surprised since the president's
wife sits on the futon board president
Christian and his wife is involved with
it so that means that it that the aide
was already politicized in the sense
that it has gone to an organization that
works with the right-wing military
government in El Salvador Carlos claims
mrs. Christianity helps raise funds for
Fuson and isn't involved with policy
decisions Melvin's decided to try a
different route after the 1990 beachside
Festival he decided to deliver the aid
themselves the aid was sent to San
Antonio Texas and put in trucks as part
of a pastor's four-piece Caravan the
aide made its way through Mexico without
a hitch and the caravan continued
through Guatemala without incident no
problems arose until they reached the
Salvadoran border
leader Tom Hansen and three other
caravan members were denied entry into
the country despite prior approval and
visas but Caravan participants were
prepared for trouble and quickly moved
into non-violent civil disobedience
right in the immigration office
mr. yogi under fully and you can
nothing their perseverance prevailed and
after 48 hours of bureaucratic delay the
caravan and its cargo were allowed into
El Salvador the humanitarian aid was
then held up in customs for several more
days in san salvador when the aid was
finally released the melons and the
church people and human rights activists
from the caravan began delivering the
aid to non-governmental agencies or NGOs
as they're called
many self-help Salvadoran citizen groups
say NGOs have a better track record than
the government of getting aid to the
people with the vice-minister to the
Salvadoran president warns of
distributing aid through NGOs but you
must guard against is in organizations
or individuals who present themselves to
represent the poor and could be actually
funneling a to terrorists that is one
thing you should guard against but a man
who works in the countryside with the
desperately poor he says aid channel
through NGOs stays within the
communities when you talk about when
someone will say that the aid that the
community received through NGOs that
will end up in the hands of the of the
subversive I think that again it's just
a political justification of trying to
to control Oh any any a that may come to
the country and the Salvadoran Minister
of the Interior says humanitarian aid it
should go through the government and not
to specific communities in the beginning
sometimes when it counts it is
a specific destination that could create
some problems because there might be
some communities might need this a more
than the communities over the eight has
been destined to but The Melvins chose
to avoid going through the government
only eight getting down here is military
aid I don't care you can call it g-men
Americans can cause humanitarian they
can call it their mammy if they want to
but it is not getting to the people down
here in any format early in the military
the first group to receive aid from the
Melbourne is with the residents of sila
dial left homeless by a major earthquake
in 1986 a social worker says the five
hundred families who have set up camp on
top of the city dump never received any
of the 129 million dollars sent by the
US said I'm in flip the rebels be
publicity honestly know the money is in
the hands of the government
they gave most of my money the medicine
and the food to the armed forces the
Commodities who denounce human rights
abuse may help the families that were
killed and disappeared medicine to those
who need them
appreciate think though and I gotta I
mean what's the Memphis the American
people are beautiful give what they have
they get they can develop let me see
look at the end it's dangerous for these
people to even receive humanitarian aid
while this aid was being delivered there
was an undercover policeman across the
street photographing the whole event The
Melvins also designated aid for three
villages in the countryside the put laws
are populated by Salvador and refugees
from the Civil War who fled to Honduras
and have recently returned to what's
left of their land the people who live
in San Siro Moussa moved on
rebuilding The Melvins gave the money to
finish this school malnutrition is
rampant in chalatenango Rosa Mendes La
Mora in Val Verde received aid to
increase their ability to feed
themselves
the people who live here in this
community will be receiving aid raised
by the beachside festival they'll be
getting clothing medicine a tractor and
a truck to take their produce to market
the people in the town of Isla Verde
planned a reception for their compadres
at flamingo design The Melvins but like
most foreigners the government wouldn't
allow The Melvins out in the countryside
the people were disappointed what you've
just seen about the delivery of
humanitarian aid in El Salvador is
happening all around the world
government corruption and civil war will
have to be brought under control the
world will have to initiate if it's a
delivery system particularly because
world disasters are growing at a faster
rate than world finances reporting from
El Salvador
Susan de Brava behind the headlines